♪ ♪ ♪
- Voici le petit train bleu qui
veut révolutionner le transport
ferroviaire grâce à l'hydrogène,
en essai en Allemagne.
Terminus : Sigmaringen
et son célèbre château.
Un trajet de 1 h 20
depuis Hechingen, 50 kilomètres
plus au Nord, avec une vingtaine
de stations. Sure e genre
de petites lignes régionales,
l'électrification serait bien
trop chère. Pour l'instant,
le diesel est ce qu'il y a
de plus économique,
mais il s s s inconvénients.
Depuis le moi j j juin,
le train bleu remplace
quatre fois par jour les trains
jaunes qui, eux, fonctionnent
au diesel.
- Ce train bleu est
un prototype, prêté par le
constructeur Alstom, pour des
clients potentiels : ici,
la SWEG, compagnie ferroviaire
qui appartient au land
de Bade Wurtemberg.
Les trains bleus et jaunes
sont identiques : ce sont
des Coralia, sauf que le bleu,
baptisé iLint, fonctionne
avec des piles à combustible
à hydrogène : zéro émission, si
ce n'est un peu de vapeur d'eau.
Manuel Schweitzer fait partie
du club fermé des tout premiers
conducteurs du premier train
à hydrogène du monde.
Avec son collègue conducteur
de trains diesel, ils discutent
des différences.
Le train bleu quitte
Sigmaringen pour la deuxième
fois. Il roule surtout en fin
d'après-midi. Les différences
avec le train diesel
sont frappantes.
"Il est tsisisisisilencieux, ct
comme un tramway dans une grande
ville. Il est agréable
à conduire, c'est formidable.
Par rapport au diesel, les
émsososososont plus écologiques,
c'est bon pour la nature
et c'est plus agréable
pour les passagers
parce qu'il n'y a pas de bruit.,
les passagers apprécient
nettement ces différences.
"C'est beaucoup mieux que les
autres trains parce ononononont
bruyants et ils puent. Celui-ci
sent bon, il est agréable."
Ce jeune homme le prend
cinq à spapapapapar semaine
pour le travail.
"J'aime bien prendre ce train
parce qu'il protège
l'enenenenenent. Il est plus
silencieux que le train normal
et c'est beaucoup plus agréable
pour les gens qui viventononono,
et pour moi aussi.
Cette britannique vit
et étudie en Allemagne.
"Je prends l'autobus
et le train chaque jour
et si je peux, j'en profite
pour réduire mon empreinte
écologique."
♪ ♪ ♪
Le train bleu a été conçu
à Salzgitter, en Basse-Saxe,
par Alstom. Cette usinecocococo,
qui roulent partout en Europe.
Mais ces trains jaunes au diesel
devraient être remplacés
dans 12 ou 15 ans par les bleus,
les Coralia iLint,
montés sur une ligne parallèle.
Ceux-ci sont les 14 premiers à
être livrés sous peu au système
ferrovddddddd
de Basse Saxe.
L'arme secrète du train bleu
est canadienne : c'est la pile
à combustible conçue
par Hydrogenics de Mississauga,
en Ontario, qui vient d'être
acquise par Cummins, le géant
américain des moteurs,i i i i ie
écologique. Le iLint est plus
cher qu'un train diesel, mais
ce le sera de moins en moins.
"Les trains coûtent un peu plus
cher, mais il faut penser
à l'ensemble du modèle,
l'investissement et les coûts
d'x x x x x x x x d'un train
à hydrogène, la maintenance et
l'approvisionnement énergétique
sont déjà moins chers que les
coûts d'opération d'un diesel,oe
du prix du carburant."
Alstom possède, pour l'instant,
la seule station de recharge
en hydrogène. Le plein se fait
en vingt minutes, comme pour
le diesel. L'autonomie est
de 1000 km avec un plein et une
vitesse maximale de 140 km/h,
comme le diesel également,
mais avec pollution zéro.
La pile à combustible
à hydrogène pronnnnnnnnn
chimique avec l'oxygène de l'air
ambiant pour générer
l'électricité qui propulselelel:
ce n'est pas de l'hydrogène
vert, produit par une énergiere,
par exemple.
"L'hydrogène provient
de sources différentes.
C'est un mélange d'hydrogène
vert et de sous-produits de
l'industrie, mais nous projetons
d'avoir bientôt une majorité
d'hy"""""""""
Ce sous-produit est un
hydrogène gris, comme celui de
l'usine voisine, Salzgitter AG,
l'une des plus grosses aciériese
2,5 millions de tonnes de
charbon par an jusqu'en 2050.
Ceci dit, le petit train bleu
fait son chemin. Il a circulé A.
Il y a 27 commandes fermes
pour Francfort et une douzaine
de trains
électricité et hydrogène
en France : beaucoup d'intérêt
dansEuEuEuEuEuEuEuEuEuEurope.
Et l'Amérique du Nord?
"Le Canada et l'Amérique
du Nord sont des marchés
intéressants. Peu
sont électrifiées et il y a une
demande pour des émissions zéro.
L'hydrogène est donc une bonne
solution. Il y a de l'expertise
dans les plelelelelelelelelelele
au Canada et en Amérique
du Nord, et aussi
des développement écologiques
très intéressants.
prprprprprprprprprprprête,
elle peut être appliquée
à toutes sortes de trains,
pas seulement à de petits trains
régionaux, comme celui du su
de l'Allemagne.
- C'est génial. Je pense que
c'est une idée très bien
pour le futur.
- Ce n'est pas le petit train
bleu qui sauvera la planète,
mais il indique une des bonnes
voies à suivr